مشاهدينا نشير الى مجموعه من الاخبار
العاجله اذ اصدر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن مذكره رئاسيه تطالب الحكومه
الاجنبيه التي تتلقى اسلحه امريكيه بتقديم
ضمانات المكتوبه حول الالتزام بالقانون
الدولي
والامريكي المذكره الامريكيه تطلب من
وزيري الخارجيه والدفاع تقديم تقارير
دوريه للكونجرس للحصول على رقابه ذات معنى
على الاسلحه التي تزود بها امريكا
الحكومات الاجنبيه دائما ضمن هذه الاخبار
العاجله المتعلقه بهذه المذكره تقول
المذكره الرئاسيه بان وزيري الخارجيه
والدفاع مسؤولان عن ضمان ان جميع الاسلحه
الامريكيه تستخدم بطريقه تتماشى مع جميع
القوانين الدوليه بما فيها القانون الدولي
الانساني وقانون حقوق الانسان الم الذكره
الرئاسيه تقول ايضا بان وزيري الخارجيه
والدفاع مسؤولان عن ضمان ان جميع الاسلحه
اذا كما ذكرنا يجب
ان تستخدم بطريقه تتماشى مع كل من القانون
وايضا السياسه الامريكيه على ايه حال
الاخبار العاجله هذه تظهر تباعا على شاشه
الجزيره ينضم الينا الان من نييورك محمد
سطوحي الكاتب والصحفي المختص في الش
الامريكي ومن حيف ايهاب جبارين الكاتب
والمختص في الشان الاسرائيلي مرحبا بكما
في هذه التغطيه المستمره من
الجزيره محمد سطوحي هذه
المذكره ما الذي يلفت الانتباه فيها في
توقيتها
تحديدا بالتاكيد هي تخص اسرائيل في هذا
التوقيت تحديدا وتلاحظ ايضا انه في نفس
الوقت مجموعه كبيره من السناتور اعضاء
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي من الحزب الديمقراطي
من جانبهم ايضا يقومون بعمل تعديلات في
تشريع تقديم الاسلحه لاسرائيل واوكرانيا
بانه ايضا يكون هناك رقابه
وضمان لاسلوب استخدام هذه الاسلحه وان
يكون للكونجرس متابعه لهذا الامر ف قد لا
يمر ذلك في التعديلات او تلك التعديلات قد
لا توافق عليها القاعده الجمهوريه من
اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ وبالتالي يكون هناك
صعوبه لتمريرها ولكن في نهايه الامر من
الواضح تماما انه سواء من اعضاء الكونجرس
من الديمقراطيين والان هذا الامر التنفيذي
من الرئيس الامريكي كلها اشارات ذات معنى
انه الولايات المتحده غير راضيه عن
الاسلوب الذي تستخدمه اسرائيل في عملياتها
الحربيه في قطاع غزه و كلمات الرئيس
الامريكي اليوم هي مؤشر ربما الاقوى من
نوعه في انتقاده للعمليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بلغه واضحه وبلغه حاده من
الواضح ايضا انه هذا جاء نتيجه الاجتماعات
التي اجراها توني بلينكن مع رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنجامين نتنياهو والحكومه
الاسرائيليه وكانت تؤشر على انه هذه
الحكومه لا تريد التعاون على الاطلاق
بالنسبه لاي هدن انسانيه وانها تريد المضي
قدما في عملياتها العسكريه خاصه في منطقه
رفح وهذا ما اعربت واشنطن بشكل صريح عن
اعتراضها عليه اذا المؤشرات كلها تؤكد
تصاعد التوتر بين الجانبين واللغه الحاده
التي يستخدمها الامريكيون الان المهم الان
ترجمه هذه اللغه الى خطوات عمليه ايهاب
جبارين يرى محمد سطوحي
بان هذه المذكره
يقصد بها جو بايدن اسرائيل خاصه ان نتحدث
عن وقت حرب وايضا اعتداءات في الضفه
الغربيه وكان لواشنطن ما قالته في هذا
الصدد في تقرير كيف س تلقف نتنياهو هذه
الرساله نعم تحياتي صباح الخير استاذ محمد
وضيفك الكريم يعني ربما للحظه نسينا ان
هنالك حرب خفيه ما بين الاداره الامريكيه
وحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو يجب ان هذا العمر
بعين الاعتبار في نهايه المطاف الحرب
واضحه من يذهب الى الانتخابات اولا يخسر
على هذا كان يراهن بايدن تحديدا في كل
خاصيه
هذه الهدنه بان يستطيع في غضون ثلاثه او
اربعه اشهر ما قبل منتصف هذا العام ان
ياتي
بورقه شبه مسوده لاتفاقيه اتفاقيه سلام او
ايا كان يقدمها امام الشارع الامريكيه
كانجا جاز لرئيس امريكي يتفاخر به امام
شرعه واما بالنسبه لبنيامين نتنياهو في
نهايه المطاف الصوره واضحه هنالك حاجه
ماسه للتلاعب بقواعد الاداره الامريكيه
ولطالما لا يستطيع بايدن ان يقدم مثل هذه
الاطروحه و في ظل كل التوترات الموجوده
وربما حتى يعني ماخذ اخرى على بايدن بكل
خصوصيه العمر والسن وما الى ذلك فواضح جدا
ان
استبداله سوف يكون اسهل وحضور ترامب الى
الواجهه او ايا كان يعني الى الواجهه ممكن
ان يكون افضل بالنسبه لاداره بنيامين
نتنياهو وبذلك نتنياهو يضمن بان ياتي شريك
امريكي يكون اكثر توافقيه مع رؤيته في كل
ما
يخص يعني رؤيته للقضيه الفلسطينيه وكيفيه
تعاملها معها هذه هي ال في هذه النقطه
والاشاره الى ترامب الموضوع ربما سابق
لاوانه ولكن
اتذكر بعد خساره ترامب كان هناك الكثير من
الخلاف الذي ظهر على السطح بين ترامب
ونتنياهو وانتقادات ايضا لاذعه كانت من
ترامب
حينها بدون شك بدون شك لكن في نهايه
المطاف نح نتحدث عن حاله حرب يعني و فقط
قبل ايام كذلك ترامب كان لديه تحفظ من كل
ما يجري ومن اداره نتنياهو وما الى ذلك
لكن في نهايه المطاف نحن نتحدث عن
يعني الاداره الجمهوريه في نهايه المطاف و
وكيفيه رؤيتها وكيفيه توافقها
مع اسرائيل هذا في المقام الاول بل اكثر
من ذلك هنالك ما يحاول ان يقوم به نتنياهو
في نهايه المطاف ان يثبت للعالم القاعده
البسيطه التي تحاول اسرائيل ان تثبتها دائ
من يعادي اسرائيل يخسر وهذا ما يحاول ان
يقوم به بنيامين نتنياهو لكن الاداره
الامريكيه في نهايه المطاف تتعامل مع
اسرائيل بازدواجيه معايير واضحه في يعني
في حين انها تتعامل مع في محاوله للحفاظ
على مصالح اسرائيل العامه بدون انشك ان
مثل هذه المسودات
وغيرها مما تقوم به الاداره الامريكيه
كذلك هنالك محاوله للضرر والماس بحكومه
بنيامين نتنياهو بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر طبعا
مجال ومساحه يعني الضرر بحكومه نتنياهو في
ظل المراوغه على الحفاظ على مصالح اسرائيل
العامه ضيقه وضئيل جدا جدا محمد
سطوحي قبل هذه المذكره التي نحن بصدد
مناقشه ما جاء فيها كان
هناك خطاب او كلمه لبايدن في البيت الابيض
قال فيها بان سلوك الرد الاسرائيلي في قطع
غزه تجاوز الحد كيف يمكن وصف هذا التصريح
من الرئيس الامريكي وما ابعاده المتوقعه
في
تقديرك هو تصريح قوي هو اقوى ادانه لما
تفعله اسرائيل في غزه حتى الان كان هناك
تصعيد تدريجي في لهجه الاداره الامريكيه
على مدى الاسابيع الاخيره ولكن هذا هو
اكثرها حده ومن الرئيس الامريكي شخصيا
وكما ذكرت من الواضح انهم صدموا او اصيبوا
بخيبه امل كبيره من رد الفعل الاسرائيلي
على مفاوضات وقف اطلاق النار ووجدوا انه
من الضروري الان التصعيد على الاقل علنيا
من جانب الاداره ومن الرئيس الامريكي
شخصيا للرد على الموقف الاسرائيلي بشان
مفاوضات الهدنه او الوقف المؤقت لاطلاق
النار مقابل تبادل للمحتجزين في الجانبين
فمن هنا اضطر الرئيس الامريكي ان يجعل
موقفه اكثر صراحه وفي مؤتمر صحفي في يسمعه
العالم كله ايضا واعتقادي انه من المهم
جدا في هذه الحاله انه لا يمكن ابدا الصمت
على ما يقوله الرئيس الامريكي بالنسبه لما
قيل بشان مد المساعدات لقطاع غزه من
الجانب المصري اعتقد ان الحكومه يجب ان
توضح موقفها بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع لانه
ليس من المفهوم انه الامر يحتاج الى
مكالمه منه للرئيس المصري لكي يقنعه
بتمرير المساعدات الانسانيه لقطاع غزه
فبالتالي انا اعتقد ان الامر عندما يصدر
من الرئيس الامريكي شخصيا يحتاج الى كثير
من التوضيح والردود لانه هذا لا يمكن
الصمت بشانه ويجب ان يكون هناك رد مصري
واضح وقوي بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع